bringing the conversation back to the
couch Raymond why wouldn't they head for
California why not there they could go
to college if they wanted for free right
they would get cash payouts they get
free health care food stamp benefits
housing assistance hey the list goes on
well look they go from one Sanctuary
City to another and Governor hokel is
now saying we should Deport these people
because of their alleged criminal
activity here's the problem she too is
doing what I call the hcal twostep she
says Deport them on the one hand on the
other hand she just opened up 4,000
state jobs to these illegal aliens this
is a big problem here in New York I was
at that place yesterday believe it or
not the sight of that attack on those
cops it is in front of a migrant shelter
which is on 42nd Street between Madame
tusos and where Aladdin is playing you
don't have to buy a ticket to see a
whole new world it's right there out on
the street it's a disaster what we're
seeing but to put a migrant shelter one
of 200 now in New York in the middle of
the the tourist District in the biggest
city of the world boggles the mind and
we're going to see more of this because
the da doesn't care and they really
aren't changing anything try to find a
cop in Times Square they're practically
non-existence because they're down a
thousand plus cops and it doesn't look
like it's going to get better any
quicker yeah and when you do find them
say Thank you Lisa as as Raymond talks
about da Bragg I mean it's such a joke
too you know the purpose of bail is to
ensure that you return to court and so
the the joke is on Alvin Bragg so many
times over because of course these guys
don't have any ties to New York
whatsoever they are so long gone as
Daniel Penny's attorney said he finds
this all very confounding that's just
the tip of the iceberg well and that's
America today I mean can we can we
debase ourselves anymore as a nation I I
mean I want everyone to go back and and
look at those photos of these criminals
flipping us off and that's what it is
that's what these people think of us
that's what they think of America they
break our laws likely lying about Asylum
when they're coming here for other
reasons they're not escaping persecution
they're coming here for economic reasons
they're coming here to take advantage of
us or they Goda ways who broke the law
coming in here as well so this is what
they think of us they come here and then
they flee to California where they're
going to be provided housing assistance
food stamps Health Care financial aid
further taking advantage of Americans
and then we have idiot Republicans like
Dan crenchaw and James Langford who are
trying to cautify this Invasion and
perpetuity by allowing up to 5,000
illegal immigrants per day so you know
the joke is on all of us because this is
absolutely ridiculous and I hope
Americans wake up and realize that you
know we're getting screwed well I hope
the Americans that wake up extend to
Congress Kaye because through through no
fault of the 150 Democrats that voted
against a bill to deport those arrested
for illegal drunk driving I mean think
about Melissa Powell and her son who was
killed by a resist drunk driver illegal
immigrant out of Colorado there's not
enough time in the show for me to name
all of the people who have died at the
hands of recidivist drunk driving
illegal immigrants and 150 Democrats say
no it's inexcusable completely
inexcusable as are the laws in these
blue jurisdictions look you know you
mentioned these guys playing to
California do you realize that they are
entitled by law to sex change surgery in
California should they get there and
decide oh today I feel like I'm a woman
that is insane I mean that is insane but
these guys theoretically are entitled to
that when they arrive if they ever
arrive in California if that was their
destination now yes you had those
liberals who voted 150 against that law
but what is interesting is this story
has struck such a cord because it's so
unjust on so many levels the fact that
these guys could have been near our
school children the fact that these
individuals could have displaced kids
from their soccer fields Liberals are
acting a little bit differently Veronica
Veronica Escobar of the progressives has
called out Democrats saying all of a
sudden you guys are sounding like
Republicans we don't want to sound like
Republicans on this issue Kathy hokel
the Democrat mayor these guys should be
deported I'm paraphrasing her there I
went on some liberal networks they're
all covering this story and on CNN I
watched this host in shock and a when a
law enforcement officer came on and said
this so what the detectives are telling
me detectives around New York is that
there are Crews here and they're Crews
that steal things they operate in New
York do all their stealing go to Florida
to spend the money and come back and I'm
like why don't they say stay and steal
in Florida they said because you go to
jail in Florida and the CNN host was
stunned my point is all of a sudden the
liberal Works liberals in general are
taking notice because the American
people are saying this is manifestly
unfair and in the process in the interim
while we wait for them to come to their
senses we're all in danger the safety is
eroded New York Post today calling it
The sad ugly future of New York I argue
it's the sad ugly present and now police
officers hamstrung even further they
have to record every stop yeah every
minute there is a hamstringing and um a
castration occurring of so many people
trying to do the right thing in the city
the right thing in this country by those
liberals even if they are slowly coming
around I don't want to wait for their
puberty to Peak I'm sick of it people
are dying they won't Rob or pick
anybody's pocket down in Florida because
Floridians are allowed to
pack um point you said America I say
Democrat Democrats let these criminals
into the United States unlawfully
Democrats let these criminals out onto
the streets no bail after assaulting
police officers Democrats let these
criminals avoid void being turned over
to ice and Democrats let these criminals
suckle at the tee of taxpayers until
everybody stops voting for Democrats
this will continue but this like the
bail reform it is very hard to unravel
and undo the damage these leftwing
lunatics have done to New York and all
of these states you're right and let me
just add the voting for the Democrats
yes but also please normal conservative
people run because oftentimes the only
Buffet on those ballots are a buffet of
socialist
liberal Wast of fles they B they're
bothered by the children who are on the
Subways children selling candy where's
um Child Protective Services they're
illegal kids on the subway selling candy
more things hey everyone I'm Emily
compano catch me and my co-hosts Harris
vulner and Kaye meeni on outnumbered
every weekday at 12:00 p.m. Eastern or
sets your DVR also don't forget to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
for daily highlights